if ukrainians were hopeful russia might
soften its demands a 90-minute summit
made it clear that won't happen
we cannot stop the war if the country
which committed the aggression the
invasion does not have a desire to do so
said ukraine's foreign minister after
the meeting
two weeks in there's no movement toward
a cease-fire
and no progress on establishing
humanitarian corridors to help the
beleaguered citizens of ukraine escape
negotiation may be impossible because
russia's claims are so detached from
reality
we didn't attack ukraine proclaimed
russian foreign minister sergey lavrov a
situation threatening directly the
russian federation security was there he
said
lavrov dismissed concerns about civilian
casualties as pathetic outcries
he even suggested the russian bombing of
a maternity hospital was justified
claiming the building was occupied by
ukrainian radicals not women or doctors
on social media russian diplomats
falsely claimed these pregnant women
seen in the rubble were actually actors
russian forces are at the very least
operating with reckless disregard for
the safety of civilians as russian units
launch artillery and airstrikes into
urban areas
the defiance stretches all the way to
the kremlin where vladimir putin told
his cabinet a newly isolated russia
would emerge stronger than ever
ukraine's fierce resistance may still
upend those plans
the door remains open to a diplomatic
end to the war but ukraine is clear
surrender will never be an option
jackson prosco global news washington